let me get a question in jesse uh pastor
jesse reverend jesse lee peterson jesse
lee pedersen radio and tv show host tell
me this when you mention god
uh i sincerely want to know do you do
you believe that jesus is actually
god the father or do you believe he was
sent by god
what is not when we're taught
without a doubt jesus christ is the son
of god
and god's nature his spirit dwelt and
steered us in him
in order that he may get the work
done on earth become the light of the
world
and
christ made it
clear that he wasn't god he said i'm the
son of god i was set by god
and greater worship that i'm doing that
you should do
he will go to the father and pray
and seek his will
and so
if god with god he wouldn't go to
himself to seek his own will he would
know his will
so he's clearly
the son of god and not god can you tell
me what you when you say son of god so
we can just have a better understanding
because you know the the human mind
understands when you say sun you
understand you can have a literal sun
you can have an adopted son
or metaphorical these are the three
options so what do you mean and you're
the right man for the job because you're
a pastor so just respectfully asking you
and these are the conversations that
we're talking about us having to
understand each other better so what do
you actually mean that jesus was the son
of god can you please elaborate on that
yeah i will but are you saying people
are so dumb that when they hear that
jesus christ is the son of god they
don't understand what a son is
well that's the
these are the options so you can have a
literal son of god so are you saying he
was literally the begotten son of god
was he an adopted son or was he is this
metaphorical and the reason i'm asking
is well let me and i'll tell you uh
after you yeah because the question
doesn't make sense
no actually what what that is trying to
ask is
this emotional question but it doesn't
make sense like for let me let
let me go people know the difference
between a son and a father and this is
this is and this is again we love jesus
as a mighty messenger if you say any uh
disrespectful thing about jesus as a
muslim you can go straight to the
hellfire i just want you to know that i
mean
there's no playing around you know we
get offended if you offend jesus so well
yeah y'all won't defend white people in
america but listen
so we know that uh dogs have puppies you
know cows have calves uh cats have
kittens so when you say god had a son
please elaborate what do you mean
god
sent his son
um jesus christ
through mary
so that we the people
the people who were lost they had no way
back to the father
because adam believed in the woman
after she believed in the devil
and so the woman became the man's god
and the devil became the woman's god
and as a result there was no way back to
the father to god
and every man every human being that
born through the woman
are dying they are born of the devil
and so what christ did he needed a man
to come that was not of the woman but of
the father
and so he created his son jesus christ
put his spirit in him and sent him
through the woman so that all who
believe in the son
will believe in the father and that's
why we're urging
boys and girls men and women
to return to their earthly fathers
by not resenting them forgiving them for
not protecting them from their mothers
because mothers turn the children away
from their fathers
and they recreate their children in
their image which is of the devil
and so when the kids return to the
earthly fathers
they will return to god they have to
forgive their mothers for turning them
away from their fathers and recreate
them in their image and return to their
earthly father forgive the father for
not protecting them
from the mother
because they didn't understand the
spirit of the mother and so once you
love your earthly father you can love
god but if you don't love your earthly
father
you would never ever ever love god you
will not know him you'll read about him
and intellectually learn that way but
you won't know him you won't have a
personal relationship with him you're
just to be an emotional intellectual
talking about god when in reality you're
a hypocrite and pharisee because you
don't know god and you keep other people
away from him
dr seville you want to uh yeah i just
want to say you know uh i'm i'm not sure
brother jesse if you know what we
believe about jesus
i don't think you may know it so i can
quickly ask you this question right uh
when eddie is saying that you know a son
can be taken as either a literal way or
a metaphorical way
i'm assuming that you take jesus to be a
literal son of god do you
jesus christ was the son of god
even when he lived on earth in the
physical body
he was still the son of god dwelling in
jesus
answer the question jesse come on just
father jesse
yes or no
yes no no respectfully jesse come on you
know how you come on me we're buddies
now so we can do this come on what do
you mean by literally the sun what do
you mean by that sure sure so according
to the bible according to the eastern
bible dictionary i read the bible many
times by the way just to let you know
according to
i read the bible many times so i'm just
quoting you from the bible dictionary
and also from the bible there are many
many places where the bible mentions
about a son of god in a metaphorical way
for example according to the eastern
bible dictionary if you go under the
label son of god or sons of god it says
anyone who is a righteous person is
called as a son of god
so for that reason brother jesse if you
look into the old testament the book of
psalms chapter number 2 verse number 7
it says that david was the begotten son
of god jacob was the son of god even
adam is called as the son of god in luke
chapter 3 verse number 38 so since the
word son is there do you take them as
literal or metaphorical
well because and you're right all who
have returned to the fathers are sons
and daughters of god
and
uh christ and god is a spirit so
spiritually jesus christ is the son of
god who lived here a monster for a while
in the physical body
and so
i hope hopefully that answer yeah he is
the spiritual
son
of god
so so not in a literal way so i mean
jesus is no different than david and
jacob
and adam because they're all sons of god
from a biblical point of view any
righteous person is called as a son of
god
only if they've been born of god if they
have not been born of god they're not
sons of god they're sons and daughters
of the devil
right so so the bottom line is there are
many many sons of god in the bible and
jesus is no different that's the point
we are trying to get
on
what do you mean he is no different
yeah because he's just like david who is
also called as the begotten son of god
he's just like jacob who is also
metaphorically son of god and like adam
who's also metaphorically a son of god
see god see
there are only two categories in in this
whole universe
one is the creator
anyone anyone who is not a creator is
called as the creation
so jesus is a creation of god in a
metaphorical way people may say he's the
son of god he said jesus is just the
creation of god
see
there is a creator and anything else
anything who anyone who is not a creator
what is the name for that person
he's a creation you and us you and i we
are a creation we are not creators
if jesus is not god that means he is not
god he is a creation of god
so in that sense jesus was a human he
was a prophet the way that jesus said
that i am a prophet of god many many
times in in the bible
so we say that god gave a message to
jesus about inviting people to worship
only one god
which is there in in the quran chapter 3
verse number 51
jesus is saying and this is god is
quoting
so jesus is saying
in allah
verily allah is my lord and your lord
worship him alone and that is the
straight path
but the amazing thing brother jesse is
exactly similar thing is mentioned in
mark chapter 12 verse number 28
a person comes to jesus and he asked him
a million dollars are you ignoring it
quote scriptures with no meaning
there is no meaning intellectually
intellectually i know that you think you
have meaning i know that you think but
you just quoted the bible like any
intellectual preaching
uh a so-called expert would do they
learn look at the preachers and and and
the uh
uh catholic priests and all therefore
they're hypocrites they quote the bible
but
on the inside the glass is dirty it's
evil they are diligent
they are they are quoting the bible with
all this mass
but inwardly their hearts are far away
from god and that's why the people
suffer
because the people listen to it never
really seeking father from within
so let us give the context to the
passage which i am going to quote mark
chapter 12 verses
you saw like
andy are you doing quote bible but
you're not giving me any understanding
at all does he sound like no
understanding about what you're saying
does he sound like a black black
preacher do all they do is quote the
bible yeah hey hey does he sound like a
black preacher also you sound like a
black intellectual preacher
[Laughter]
yeah so